and she's had some moments where you
could reach out and actually help her
because she's been struggling
and for the rest of your time together
you will wonder when this other shoe
drops and you're the other guy no that's
definitely cross my mind but I would
tell you right now man she's cheating on
herself she's cheating on her even if
she's in the middle of a breakup and by
the way that's the number one thing I
hear from folks who are like no no no no
like we're already breaking up and
there's their husband or wife has no
idea that they're already breaking
up right um I would tell you
to as hard as this is going to be I
would tell you to run and maybe um and
even after like she gets y'all get
divorced or she gets divorced and
there's six months where y are friends
whatever then maybe but I'm telling you
right now dude you're never going to be
able to sleep